hey guys speed here it's going to be my
Game of Thrones season 7 episode 4 8
dive in-depth recap and review
through all the scenes one by one it
will contain spoilers if you haven't
seen episode four then you won't want to
watch this video and like usual I will
put a timestamp link in the description
if you want to skip over the scene by
scene and go directly to the discussion
afterwards so we start off seeing the
convoy that the Lannisters have put
together filled with loot from taking
Highgarden from the Tyrells as I
mentioned in my top moments video Jaime
is noticeably shook a bit from what
Elena told him as she was drinking her
poison frog seems fairly unaffected by
the whole situation and he's mostly just
worried about getting his castle but I
think what's more important about these
two things is that we see that Jaime is
a little bummed out back at the capital
we see the taiko is very happy with the
idea that Cersei is going to pay him off
he also hints that they would like to
continue to work with the Lannisters and
once the gold returns then they would
like to you know earn some more interest
on a new loan the most important thing
we find out here is that she's thinking
of hiring sell swords and not just any
sell swords that is but the golden
company now I don't want to go too
deeply into what the golden company is
because it might not be that important
but they are known by book readers it's
actually kind of exciting but
complicated at the same time so we'll
just say that this is an interesting
development and I'll get into it more if
we learn more about these guys being
involved back at Winterfell we see what
all this hype around the cat's paw blade
amounted to and it's really just
Littlefinger trying to use it as a way
of bringing brand over his side he's not
trying to kill bran or anything of that
kind of sort he just basically gives him
the dagger as a gift with a little story
about how you know he loved his mother
and he plans to do what she would want
even though she's gone which is to take
care of her children protect their
children I guess would be the way to
describe that even though this is a
valuable
arian steel dagger bran isn't interested
even though it was once used in an
assassination attempt against him so
we're going to have to say that little
thing are struck out here and he also
gets a little shock to the system
whenever he says the word chaos brand
says chaos is a ladder and I think it's
safe to say that this shook little
finger to the core and also excited fans
at least this man but before we can go
any further with that he's interrupted
by mirror entering the room just really
quickly the call back here is from
Littlefinger's monologue back in season
3 I'm sure you all remember it but yeah
that was the point was the chaos is a
ladder and it's kind of been his mantra
since that time so there was an
underlying thing with bran was you know
what is going on with this guy he seems
really kind of dazed in a way and this
comes out even more
whenever Mira comes to say goodbye it's
actually really sad there is a great
character she lost her brother in this
journey north and she points that out
when she realizes that bran doesn't
really care that she's leaving when she
says is that all you're going to say and
he had thank you kind of in a weak-ass
way she points out that hey Jojen died
Hodor died your direwolf summer all of
us we gave up so much to get you there
and basically he just rolls with the
idea that he doesn't or isn't capable of
caring at this point she says that he
died in that tree when he says he's not
really brand anymore and it's sad to see
her go but almost exciting at the same
time because we know she's going to
visit Howland her father so we'll leave
it at that for now
but it's clear from this scene that bran
really has experienced the
transformation in this process of
becoming the three-eyed Raven then we
get a really great return that we've all
been waiting for
but just as brands was or is this a bit
bittersweet as well we see her get to
put her new skills to use right away as
she has to trick the guards into letting
her inside and then run away from them
basically and we sort of see how being
away has affected her she's at home but
it's not really home anymore we see her
reunite with Sansa in the crypts and I
listened this in the other video as well
I think that this went pretty well when
they were kids they were really opposite
and they really didn't understand each
other in a way you know we had Santa who
wanted to be a princess and we had Aria
who was the tomboy but underneath it all
they did love each other there was a
sense of family there and I think they
did connect on that level in those
crypts
expecting them to be like gushy and you
know some kind of really emotional
heartfelt reunion just doesn't living in
the work from the beginning and I think
it's a good scene to show just how much
has happened to this family when they
were spread out all over Westeros what's
more as they've both gone through so
much I mean we can't really expect that
that's all going to come out in one
scene and I was reading to the fury over
at Watcher on the walls recap when I was
having lunch earlier and I thought she
did a really good job of pointing out
the fact that how can you sum up what's
happened I mean Aria stood a significant
amount of time living with faceless men
assassins and salsa fed her abusive
husband to the happy it sounds for that
matter so it's a lot to process I'm sure
some of those things will come out more
as things continue so it does mention
that bran is there so they go up and I
wouldn't say things normalized since
bran is full-on weird now but it takes
the pressure off at least and branches
throws it out there that he saw Aria at
the crossroads and he says I thought you
would go to King's Landing so that's a
bit of an interesting thing to talk in
the back of our minds he could see her
there but it kind of confirms that he
can't really see the future because he
didn't say I knew you were coming he
said I thought you might go to King's
Landing so we'll talk about that a
little bit more later Bren doesn't give
Aria the cat's paw blade which we saw
her pre-season promotional stuff with it
so now we know how she got it
point out that hey that is not free
nothing Littlefinger gives is free and
it kind of just points out the fact that
Arya is the lawyer of the three kind of
feel bad for brand for saying it's
wasted on a [ __ ] but you know if one
of those three is going to have it it
should be her they end up back inside
the castle walls we get a shot of
Brienne and pod that we saw in the pre
photos that HBO put out some nice little
exchange there between them pod points
out that she kept her oath to Catelyn
both of her daughters are home safely
Brienne tries to play it off because she
didn't have a hand in everything that
went down but at the end of the day it
is kind of a nice thing to think about
that they did make it that and what
would a scene at Winterfell be these
days without a shot of Littlefinger
scheming around checking out the
situation wondering what's going on and
how it affects him down at Dragonstone
we catch a glimpse of Dany and Miss Andy
having a little conversation about the
fact that something may or may not have
gone down between her and grey worm this
catches Danny's attention but they don't
get to get into it because John wants
her to check out these caves before he
starts mining the dragonglass it's
actually a pretty big space down there
so we know there's plenty of it and kind
of see it all over the walls like veins
of it of course that's not why he
brought her down there though he takes
her a little bit deeper and somewhat
dramatically reveals these carvings that
are down there that came from the
children of the forest
she's pretty noticeably taken aback by
the history involved which is cool but
the most important thing that he's
trying to show her is that they had to
work together there's a depiction of the
White Walkers there's a depiction of the
White Walkers and then there's another
one where we see the men and the
children of the forest working together
John points out that this is what
they'll have to do and of course we go
back to where we were and she wants him
to bend the knee he's still unwilling to
do so and it comes up a little bit later
but I'm sure I'm not the only person
who was really starting to notice that
there's real sexual tension between
these two we'll talk about that more
later but this had an intimate spin on
it you know I'm saying so it's different
than when we saw them talking with their
advisors nearby the other big moment
here is that when she's trying to
explain to him that aren't his people's
lives more important than that pride the
pride that he has to give up to bend the
knee it's almost a word-for-word
retelling of what he said to Mance
Rayder when Stannis was going to execute
mance for not bending the knee himself
so you could see that John didn't
understand it back then but now he kind
of does and it puts them in the same
position before we can find out too much
more about what they're thinking about
after this tender moment tyrion and
varys break the bad news about Casterly
Rock there are loads on tearing a little
bit and I think she has a pretty good
reason to do so while his plan looks
really good on paper so far it's
produced nothing but they glosses for
her of course it's not all his fault but
that's what a hand does so nobody said
the job was going to be easy Tyrion
either way she wants to head to the red
key and just take it out anything
Styrian points out that they've talked
about this before and I mentioned in the
other video that maybe it wouldn't be
such a bad idea a lot of people got
upset about that thought and brought up
the wildfire and everything but it is
war there's going to be destruction and
people are going to die but regardless
of what we think she turns to Jon Snow
which is a pretty big moment and he
frantically tells her the same thing
that everybody else is saying but puts
it in a different perspective
it basically says you know you've done
something that no one thought was
possible you brought Dragons back into
the world people follow you because they
think maybe you can do other impossible
things like make the world a better
place
if you go over there and burn down the
Red Keep and destroy King's Landing
you're basically going to show them that
you're no different than any of the
people that have ruled over them before
that ends there we go back up to
Winterfell Arya is roaming around
looking like a northern young woman
which is
pretty cool she heads over to where
Brienne and pod are sparring as he wants
to get involved he wants to do a little
practicing with Brienne she kind of gets
the better of Brienne at first but as
many people have pointed out Brienne was
probably taking it easy on her at first
we get to see her showing off all the
skills she's picked up from Syrio Forel
and from the faceless men and we see
that she is definitely skilled and all
of that stuff that we watched is going
to pay off for her in the future
what Brienne gives her a kick to the
chest we can see that she's no longer
taking it easy on her but our ass still
holds her own it looks like it's a
pretty even match at the end so another
little finger are watching at the same
time I think Santa is still processing
the fact that Aria told her that she has
a list of people she wants to kill and
she probably realizes here that hey she
can actually do that little finger on
the other hand is probably thinking
something along the lines of I really
liked it here a lot better when I only
had to worry about dealing with Sansa
Aria is going to be a problem we go back
for a little bit of comedy relief and a
short conversation that Davos has as
they're walking down the staircase he
points out that jon is checking out
demerits to which John switches gears
and says hey look man we don't have time
for any of this the real problem is the
night king I've seen them and all this
other nonsense but the takeaway here is
definitely that not only is John
thinking about Daenerys in that way
which we can tell by his terrible
attempt at pretending like he's not it's
also a viable way to end the situation
of him not being able to bend the knee
and her not being able to help him if he
doesn't do it and at this point for me
it became pretty clear that they are
going to become lovers if not more I
know people don't like the idea but
really it's just unavoidable at this
point it makes a lot of sense for a lot
of reasons and as I mentioned in the
other video nobody here knows that
they're related and even though the
people who are really against this idea
don't like it because they're related it
doesn't matter
all in the Targaryen family so you're
just going to have to get over it and
make a when they talk to miss Andy and
she kind of reinforces this ideas well
more on the bastard side of things
though right she says that marriage
doesn't exist so she doesn't understand
what a bastard is because that is
technically a barrier to them getting
married is that he is a bastard
Theon comes back not much happens except
for the fact that John says he was going
to kill him
other than the fact that he saved
Santa's life I still think there's a
possibility that these two will
reconcile like I mentioned in my fee on
do but we don't see much of it here it's
almost an afterthought in basically what
happens is that we find out when Theon
asked that Daenerys is gone we pretty
much know where she went she didn't go
to King's Landing though she went with a
compromise which was the attack the army
so we go to the field of fire 2.0
instead we get a little bit of Randall
still being a jerk he wants to flog some
people to get things moving find out
that his son Dickon is actually a little
bit more of a human being we get a
little tender moment where he talks
about the fact that he had to kill
people that he knew and that's how war
actually is
Rondo's his bran stuff was just getting
old I think I would have liked to have
seen him die here but we'll get to that
in a minute but then we find out that
the battle is about to begin
as the Dothraki is rolling over the land
that separates them from the Lannister
army
Jamie didn't seem to have his scouts out
there I guess because they're not too
far away whenever they realized that
they're coming and it's serious I mean
this is a serious situation just with
the Dothraki coming in Jamie does think
they could hold them off but when we see
Daenerys break through the cloud line we
realized that they have no frigging
possible chance so this was an episode
that was going a really good clip before
that pretty much everything was
interesting and moving things forward
and then we get into the Battle of the
season up until this point I talked
about it a lot in my other video so I'm
not going to break it down other than
the broad strokes here what we see is we
see that the Dothraki are as advertised
I mean they are a serious power on
horseback they basically walk right
through the shield walls and then we see
just how effective the Dragons really
are dinero's only has drilled on with
her but she starts cutting through the
line herself but the fire we see a lot
of people really dying in horrible ways
Jaime's almost killed but dickin comes
in to save his life which may be
important later on down the road because
Jaime only has one hand he has to try to
send Bronn to go shoot the giant balista
the Scorpion giant crossbow whatever you
want to call it we see that Tyrion rolls
up and he watches things go down Bronn
finally gets a shot in where he can hit
Drogo
after missing once it definitely hurts
him he loses control starts to fall but
he's able to bring it back together in
order to burn the weapon as mentioned I
think bran could have died right here
but instead he gets away I think that
would have been a good end for his story
but they had another idea in mind as the
dragon comes down after being injured
Daenerys gets off his back tries to pull
the bolt out of the shoulder Tyrion
watches in horror as Jamie decides that
he's going to charge the Queen he picks
up a spear takes off but drove on sees
him coming before he gets there and
decides to burn him but I don't know
where bran comes in to knock him off
those horse knock him into the water
there and save his life now there was
some speculation after the fact that we
see Jaime sinking in the water wearing
full armor and that maybe he would die
and as I mentioned in my other video you
know I can't prove that he didn't die
because they don't show them in the
trailer but it seems very very unlikely
and the more interesting question is
what's going to happen when he pops out
and I talked about that in the trailer
breakdown so I won't do it here
the battle was amazing no one can argue
that if you just skip the scene by scene
and are joining the video welcome and
talk about some of the big points and
some of the other things that come up so
yeah the stark family reunion wasn't
warm and fuzzy but it was awesome they
didn't mess this up in my opinion took a
while for me to warm up to brand being a
little bit different but as I mentioned
in my other video I think it's okay I
think that's alright so also I think had
after that sighting I think Santa really
kind of has a different kind of respect
for Arya where she's been what she's
done and I think it shows growth in her
that we didn't see whenever they were
little I think that will be reciprocated
the other way because that's faith that
they both have useful skills that they
picked up from their time being away
they're not the same
and of course brands are way over in the
other end but hopefully they got that
you know that's what I took away from it
that everybody realizes that they all
have an important role to play going
forward course Branson is the most
important on the supernatural plane or
the you know the war for the dawn that's
coming but the other two sisters have
important roles to play as well and
that's not even to talk about Jon Snow
who's not there at the moment the Theon
Jon reunion will be put on the back
burner
beyond what we saw I'm not really sure
what to think about Theon's past going
forward I mentioned this in the other
video and you know of course he wants to
save yara but I'm not sure that he'll be
able to do that and no I do think he's
on a redemptive arc it's just not really
clear where he comes in to get that
Redemption Jon and Daenerys becoming a
couple is clearly becoming more of a
undeniable reality of this situation I
think that when they were in the cave
that the tension was real we'd see
little glimpses of it before and yeah I
just don't see how there's a story that
doesn't involve them becoming intimate
before the seasons out I like the King's
Landing angle was Cersei coming up with
a new squad of self swords just in time
to lose the entirety of her forces
coming back from Highgarden for the
this part and it really comes down to
the fact that this is a stalemate each
time we thought we knew how things would
go in a lopsided direction and what we
find is that even whenever Cersei seemed
to take a big lead it always comes back
to no one's going to win this war the
stark reality is that there is no
importance in who sits on the Iron
Throne these two sides are going to go
back and forth long enough for the
knight King down to the vex can change
up the whole frickin thing so yeah that
seems to be where things are going now
I'd love to hear you guys have thoughts
about it I did my trailer breakdown
talked about what we saw there I'll be
doing follow-up videos about some of the
points that stand out from that but yeah
I think that the war for Westeros is
looking like a stalemate I think that
Jon bending the knee to Daenerys is
looking like a stalemate I mean that's
not really the right word but I don't
see that moving forward so I think that
the relationship angle is going to come
into play I think the starts to doing
pretty damn good for all that they've
been through had to love when bran said
chaos is a ladder and then when Arya
said that she learned her new skills
from no.11 Brienne asked who taught you
that if you haven't seen the next
episode is called Eastwatch and I think
it just confirms what we've already
pretty much known all of this is headed
towards the war for the dawn so yeah
please like this video if you enjoyed it
make sure you subscribe to my channel
and turn on notifications so you know
when I upload new videos I got a pretty
good schedule coming out now so plenty
of G ot stuff throughout the rest of the
season
give me a follow over on Twitter and my
other social media accounts and we can
interact over there thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys soon